jetzt kommen wir zu einem nicht ganz so
schönen Thema was aber immer mehr
Deutsche auch beschäftigt und das ist
das Thema Auswandern aus Deutschland
da kann ich einiges dazu sagen also ich
stehe kurz vor dem Prüfungen ich bin im
dritten Lehrjahr als Pflegefachfrau und
ja nach meiner Ausbildung möchte ich auf
gar keinen Fall in Deutschland bleiben
ich sehe es überhaupt nicht ein die
Spritpreise werden teurer die Mieten
steigen
stromgas man kann sich das heutzutage
alles gar nicht mehr leisten ich denke
mir halt so nach meiner Ausbildung was
kommt da alles auf mich zu die ganzen
Fixkosten alles drum und dran ist da
also da fällt einem alles auf die Decke
und dann denkt man eigentlich nur so
wenn man schon so viel schuftet wenn man
schon irgendwie
so viel Geld so viele Ausgaben hat so
dann lieber irgendwo wo man Sonne hat
wenn man irgendwie Strand hat wo man
vielleicht ein bisschen weniger braucht
aber es einem genügt wo würden sie
hingehen wollen
also es gibt ja Möglichkeiten wie zum
Beispiel Schweiz Kanada Portugal und
mich spricht Freizeit aber sehr hohe
Lebenskosten da sind sie aber noch in
Deutschland ganz günstig dabei und
Kanada ist auch extrem teuer deshalb
würde ich mich für Portugal entscheiden
ähm
surfe und auch sehr gerne Urlaub mache
und ähm genau mich das auch anspricht
ich habe mich doch schon so ein bisschen
erkundigt da gibt's auch private
Kliniken wo man so wahrscheinlich auch
Deutsche leben wo sie auch deutsche
Rentner kümmern können genau es ist ganz
spannend sie sind wirklich nicht alleine
2021 sind 329 000 Menschen mehr zu als
abgewandert und es werden schon auch
mehr die auswandern aber wie könnte
Deutschland sehen umstimmen zu bleiben
dann müsste auf jeden Fall was passieren
mit den ganzen steigenden Preisen das
wie soll ich mir das alles leisten wie
sollen sich generell die ganzen Bürger
das irgendwie leisten da gibt's Familien
die überlegen dreimal ob sie die Haribos
irgendwie dem Kind kaufen oder nicht
oder irgendwas machen wenn man die
Rechnung genau in in ihrem Beruf auch
auf nach der Ausbildung da werden sie ja
dann wahrscheinlich netto wie viel
verdient man da
zwei zwei fünf zwei acht
ach Gott Foto genau
es hängt natürlich vom Arbeitgeber ab
von es gibt viele Arbeitgeber bzw
2000 Euro netto vielleicht zwei netto ja
dann wohnen Sie in der Großstadt oder
auf dem Land ich wohne in der Großstadt
wir sind die Mieten da wie viel werden
sie für Miete zahlen müssen also sag ihn
ehrlich da war letztens eine Freundin
auf einer Wohnungsbesichtigung ich
glaube es war eine Wohnung am
Savignyplatz 13 Zimmer 1000 Euro nette
Gegend aber wissen Sie wie viele Leute
da waren über 100 Leute das tut mir eine
Wohnung genau also das heißt es gibt
bezahlt genau das heißt entweder gehst
du hin und machst dich zum Affen weil da
100 andere Leute stehen und da muss man
aber gleich sind sie auch 1000 € immer
noch auf jeden Fall arbeitet eigentlich
für die Miete dann möchte man vielleicht
auch noch Vespa fahren oder man möchte
vielleicht Motorradfahren Autofahren
oder was man so für für Wünsche hat in
der Freizeit oder so als Verkehrsmittel
wie soll man sich das leisten eigentlich
nur noch für die Lebensunterhalt geht
man schuften man macht sein Leben lang
geht man schuften und nichts dabei hat
und um die die sich daran dass es wieder
die Vorbildwirkung die die auch dafür
mit die Verantwortung tragen dass du
isst die euch ja auch viel mehr
versprochen haben und nichts davon
gehalten haben die erheben sich jedes
Jahr die Diäten immer weiter immer
weiter immer wieder 350 mehr immer
wieder beim Thema Auswandern ähm Herr
steigen sie denn so Beispiele ja also
ganz ehrlich ich möchte hier auch nicht
mein Leben lang bleiben meine Kinder
sind jetzt 15 und 12 und auch ich sehe
das so weil ich mir einfach vorstelle
wenn das hier in dieser Nummer weiter
läuft ich meine hoffentlich schaffen wir
noch den round aber wenn es soweit läuft
dann sehe ich das nämlich genauso dann
kann ich also geil
aber ist auf jeden Fall eine schöne
Klima ja und man darf sehen eins hat man
in solchen Ländern du hast definitiv
nicht
immer wieder feststelle das merke ich
auch jetzt mal nach wenn
Einkaufen wurde Tourismus ist sondern du
fährst einfach ein bisschen raus und so
mehr Kato wenn man sich anguckt was man
dafür 100 €, aber die haben in
Deutschland im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern die niedrigsten
Lebensmittelpreise natürlich sehr
gestiegen wie jetzt 67% Paprika
innerhalb eines Jahres aber
Lebensmittelpreise da kann ich ihn aber
sagen da beneiden uns aber alle unsere
Nachbarn drum als ich beispielsweise
Niederland studiert habe sind wir mit
den Autos über die Grenze gefahren und
in Deutschland einzukaufen
genau also Lebensmittelpreise fand ich
in Spanien auch immer teurer als
Deutschland
irgendwo ja das also über viele viele
Dinge und immer wieder da kommen wir
noch mal zu er hat das hat sie ja
Ausgangs gesagt du gehst arbeiten nur
noch für deine Lebenskosten und dann
auch noch schlechte Wetter zu haben mies
gelaunt der Menschen zu haben dann kommt
ja auch noch oben drauf ständig Ärger
mit irgendwelchen Leuten zusammen es ist
zumindestens eine verständliche Sache
die ich sehe und ich bin nur ein
bisschen älter ich sehe natürlich auch
irgendwann dass ich sage jetzt möchte
ich mal ein bisschen Luft schaffen jetzt
hoffe ich dass sie das Plädoyer für
Deutschland am Start haben na ich hör
das ich hatte
[Gelächter]
gucken was ist überhaupt die datscheibe
aber
jetzt mal ernst ich kann sehr ich habe
ja auch Freunde so aus mit türkischem
Hintergrund und Migranten Hintergrund
und für die ist das natürlich viel
einfacher die können sich natürlich
tatsächlich überlegen gehe ich mal wegen
jetzt zurück in die Türkei Türkei ist ja
nun auch Probleme an sich ne viele
Kunden braucht man nicht zu diskutieren
aber ich merke schon wenn ich mich so
umhöre dass viele Leute wirklich
ernsthafter denken und vor allem
hochqualifizierte Leute dass wenn das so
weitergeht hier und dieses Land in der
abwehrspirale Gerät dass sie sich dann
wirklich neu orientieren müssen und man
darf ja eigentlich vergessen die heutige
jüngere Generation die sind alle mehr
Speicher aufgewachsen ja jeder von den
kann eigentlich Englisch ist bei mir
schon ein bisschen schlechter und ähm
und die sind natürlich insofern auch
viel mobiler als dass die alten
Generationen war aber ich könnte mir
natürlich wenn ich mir jetzt überlege
also wir bekommen hier wirklich
dauerhaft 10 15% Inflation die Sektoren
in so einem Industrie Gene Bach runter
und steigen weiter an gerade ist ein
kleiner Einbruch hat
das Interview gehabt und wo er gesagt
hat wenn wir diesen Trend nicht brechen
sieht baden-fragen mit teilweise genau
und da sagte Satz also das sieht
Baden-Württemberg aus in den 30er Jahren
wie das Ruhrgebiet heute und das muss
man sich einfach von den Dynamiker
vorstellen und dann kommen sehr viele
Leute dich kenne und das wird auch bei
uns in der Familie natürlich diskutiert
was machen wir dann eigentlich ne was
machen wir denn eigentlich mit unserer
westlich verbliebenen Zukunft und das
muss die Politik jetzt einfach mal
verstehen also das dass das was wir
jetzt hier haben seit 70 Jahren glauben
die Deutschen ja immer sie haben quasi
Naturrecht auf Wohlstand wir sind die
dritte Größe Industrie Nation der Welt
irgendwie kriegen wir das immer gedruckt
und wir sind immer die Weltmeister
werden pandemieweltmeister und ich weiß
nicht was alles über Weltmeister nur im
Fußball nicht mehr und das ist jetzt
irgendwie vorbei das Land
wo kommen unsere Ärztin oder Bulgarien
die auswanderungslust aber bevor wir
jetzt alle völlig deprimiert werden in
den nächsten Tagen in den nächsten Tag
starten würde ich gerne dass jeder von
uns doch noch mal eine positive Sache an
Deutschland sagt sie beginnen
ich muss erstmal überlegen ja ich glaube
ich habe was tatsächlich dass ich
krankenversichert bin also das ist eine
ehrliche das ist was total banal ist
aber man muss sagen in Amerika zum
Beispiel nicht das ist ja alles Systemen
richtig die Krankenversicherung
die Reformfähigkeit die Reformfähigkeit
die wir jetzt auch brauchen werden also
zum Beispiel nicht funktionierende
Konzepte einfach sagt die funktionieren
nicht probieren was Neues aus
dass wir sagen können was wir denken das
und dass wir die Möglichkeit haben
umzudenken